it won't be happening in time for the
return of thousands of march breakers
but come april first fully vaccinated
travelers won't have to worry about
testing before returning home fully
vaccinated travelers may still need
still continued to undergo random
testing upon entry to canada but they
are no longer required to quarantine
while awaiting their results passengers
who are only partially vaccinated or
have not had a shot will still have to
provide a molecular test and they'll
have to stay home for two weeks while
awaiting results
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and it's a completely different set of
rules if you're setting sail cruise ship
passengers will have to test to get on
the ship and everyone on board has to be
fully vast unvaccinated travelers with
antibodies from natural infection have
been left out that immunity for most
diseases is better than the vaccination
but for the coronavirus it seems not
necessarily so it may have to do with
the
amount of virus virus particles we took
in when we infected our vaccine rates
are generally quite high over 80 percent
nationally but only 56 percent of
eligible canadians have their booster
timothy sly suggests three doses of the
covet vaccine should now be considered a
full course there is no change to the
definition of a fully
vaccinated canadian as cova cases
continue to rise in other countries
health experts will be relying on random
traveler testing and surveillance
i think we made a grievous error in
early days of omicron by banning the
very countries that had gone to great
lengths to give the red alert to the
entire world should that alarm bell be
sounded again which is likely officials
say we will adjust restrictions with the
intention of avoiding our past pandemic
mistakes jamie morocco global news
toronto